[Music]
Juneteenth is a deeply emotional moment
for enslaved people because for decades
for centuries enslaved people crave for
hope for fought for in the form of slave
rebellions running away bought their
freedom when they could and if you read
slave narratives if you listened to
spirituals from the hero slavery you
know that enslaved people longed for
freedom this was something that had been
hoped for but many believe being able to
go wherever they wanted being able to
wonder about for enslaved people it was
an expression of their freedom well Matt
folder was the one that that long wish
for I wanted a fight folks named come
along we all said nonsense and colored
children come along and asked with each
you want to go with just a mile run and
haunted she went on with and I never did
she hit that one when I think about
Juneteenth I think about it in the
context of Emancipation Day celebrations
that began January 1 1863 they took on a
whole new meaning when slavery was
formally abolished after 1865 you would
have had African American veterans who
fought in the Civil War be prominent in
these celebrations dressed
they're military guard speeches from
enslaved people the most prominent black
politicians singing of hymns spirituals
discussions of registering to vote and
slave people celebrating in public their
newfound freedom was an act of
resistance because we have to remember
slavery came to an end after a four
years bloody bloody civil war still the
bloodiest conflict in American history
many people in the south and in the
nation who did not want to see slavery
abolished fought to been now to a block
the 13th amendment
the abolition of slavery created a huge
humanitarian crisis in the south
suddenly four million people have very
little means to take care of themselves
to support themselves and do so in a
really really hostile environment so the
military was necessary to make sure that
enslaved people got the food and
medicine the shelter that they needed in
order to survive they're also there to
protect to the exhibit that was possible
free people from violence from
recriminations from slave holders from
Confederates who still hadn't given up
the fight and I remember and then ya get
stopped here and you negatory on the
calash and people no we go the grand
scheme and the people hanging over this
film that's a punishment you got next
time is peace they call old country
anger Oh
ridin horses while I wasn't born they
all run home now when the last federal
troops leave the south it's a signal to
southerners the federal government
wasn't going to put its might into
ensuring the civil rights of black
people will be observed you have twenty
thirty years later black people being
lynched in public and there isn't a
federal anti-lynching law to protect
them in most communities in America
there's a history of lynching and racial
violence and very few communities have
marked that commemorated fat
every decade since the end of slavery
black people have been more educated
accrued more wealth more status in
American society every decade since 1865
but there's been one constant in that
constant is the presence of random races
violence
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what I see enjoys fluids murder was a
white police officer attempting to
dominate in to subdue a black man who
was not resisting who could not resist
even though slavery came to an end in
1865 the desire to master and dominate
black bodies did not and we have never
dealt with that these are the kind of
stark realities that are highlighted
during a June team if black people's
lives can be expunged that erases
violence and no one is held accountable
how free are we are we free
[Music]
you
you